There’s a bunch of rocks floating up there
in space.
What separates “ohhh, pretty lights,”
from “ahhhh we’re all gonna die!!!”?
Hey everyone, Julian here for DNews.
Shooting stars have a magical ethos.
We’re told to make a wish when we see them
streak across the sky, but you should probably
already thank your lucky stars.
If we didn’t have an atmosphere, they would
be a lot more dangerous.
First of all, “shooting stars” is a misnomer,
because they’re not stars zipping about.
They’re meteoroids, bits of dust usually
left by comets or asteroids.
We see them at 70 to 120 km away, when they’re
just starting to dip into our mesosphere and
the air starts becoming dense enough to give
the meteoroid some resistance.
And it only gets more dense the closer to
Earth they get.
These meteoroids are traveling fast, between
11 and 71 km per second, and the friction
from rubbing against all that air at those
speeds heats them up as much as 1600 degrees
celsius, causing them to burn up and leave
a streak of light called a meteor.
Meteoroids the size of sand grains and smaller
enter our atmosphere every day by the truckload.
NASA estimates a hundred tons of dust hits
us every single day.
But they’re so small they don’t have enough
momentum to keep up their speed when they
hit the air.
Instead they slow down and make it all the
way to earth.
If you want to see a show, there are about
a dozen major meteor showers a year, and they
happen predictably because the Earth keeps
passing through the wake of the same comets.
Some particles the comets left behind are
about the size of pebbles, so they’re big
enough to keep up their speed and ignite.
It’s pretty impressive that we can see them
as far as 120 km away.
That should tell you a little bit about how
much energy they have at those speeds, even
though they’re itty bitty.
So imagine how much energy meteoroids have
when they’re the size of a car.
They cause huge fireballs, brighter than the
planet Venus.
Meteoroid size varies a lot, they can be up
to a hundred meters across before they’re
classified as asteroids, but so long as they’re
less than 25 meters across, the atmosphere
usually burns them up.
Sometimes upon entry they break apart with
a bright terminal flash, called a bolide.
Bolides are harmless, but the optical energy
they give off as light can be in the rage
of a hundred thousand gigajoules, a hundred
times more energetic than the bomb dropped
on Nagasaki.
Bolides are detected about 28 times a year.
So obviously our atmosphere is doing us a
solid.
More than just giving us the air we breathe
and protection from UV rays, the atmosphere
is running interference on meteoroids and
asteroids too, making sure our planet isn’t
as cratered as my face was in high school.
But who watches the watchmen?
Turns out the atmosphere needs a little help
too from earth’s magnetic field.
The magnetic field produced by the spinning
iron core diverts the charged particles the
sun is constantly shooting into space away
from our atmosphere.
If we didn’t have it, our asteroid shield
would be blown away by the solar wind.
So the Earth is shielding the atmosphere which
is shielding the Earth.
Isn’t that sweet?
Mars doesn’t have much of an atmosphere
because it has no magnetic field, and would
you look at that, it gets hit with meteorites
200 times a year.
Even with the atmosphere intercepting most
space rocks before they can impact the surface,
Earth still gets hit with a biggie every now
and then.
NASA estimates an asteroid the size of a football
field gets through and causes significant
damage to the local area once every 2000 years.
If it’s over a kilometer wide it could have
global impacts; the meteorite that wiped out
the dinosaurs was estimated to be 10 km across.
NASA isn’t leaving our fate to chance, and
is working to track dangerous Near Earth Objects.
They hope to one day send astronauts to study
a dangerous asteroid before sending said asteroid
into a harmless orbit around the moon.
Yes, it sounds like NASA got the idea from
a Bruce Willis and Ben Affleck movie.
So now you know why meteoroids burn up, but
what if they make it all the way to earth?
Trace has the scoop on meteorites here.